we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p guys i'm really taking a
lot of hits this week i was criticized
uh for saying that oprah is to some
degree responsible for dr oz because
she's the one who brought him to the
public and someone said that that's
racist how dare i accuse a black woman
of that and now i am being criticized
because i did not issue a ramadan
greeting on monday i guess take a listen
to this
good morning wendy from california
with regards to monday's show greeting
um you know
welcoming back from passover and then
it's like oh yeah and easter
wasn't it also ramadan i don't know i
would like to believe that
you're not
myopic and that you're inclusive and
that
because of inclusion inclusion that
leads to object objectivity
um
last week i was concerned
because he thought the native americans
didn't put up enough resistance and now
i don't even know what the hell she's
talking about there so the second part
i felt the native americans didn't put
up enough resistance
i i never said that okay that i that's
completely out of this world
but i guess the problem is on monday i
said hey hope everybody had a good
passover or a good easter it's good to
be back and i didn't i didn't mention
ramadan so here's the deal
i don't know what the hell is going on
as far as religion goes i know about
passover because i'm culturally jewish
okay so that that's why i know about
passover i know about easter because
it's a federal holiday it's on every
calendar
okay i don't know about anything else
going on so if someone tells me it was
ramadan it's not because i i don't in
particular not care about islam
i just i just don't know
march 2nd i looked up march 2nd was ash
wednesday i had no idea i didn't mention
it i just i don't know if it's like if
the stock market's open and whatever on
friday i noticed the stock market was
closed and i was like why is it closed i
looked it up oh it's good friday because
it's easter that's the only reason i
even figured it out um you know this
this coming week this sunday is orthodox
easter i had no idea i i looked it up
and i i found it
april 29th is lailat al-qaeda i hope i'm
pronouncing that correctly that's that's
a muslim holiday i don't know anything
there's no
let's not read in with malice to things
that are just really no big deal okay
let everybody relax all right i'm not
trying to be disrespectful to anybody
everybody's welcome to watch this show
on any day regardless of what holidays
are going on
on the bonus show today
netflix has lost viewers for the first
time in 10 years
their uh stock has absolutely crashed i
lost a bunch of money because i've owned
netflix stock for a really long time
uh i had forgotten about it and
yesterday uh i guess i lost 40 percent
okay we will talk about what's going on
with netflix omarosa manago newman has
been awarded over a million bucks in
legal fees from the trump campaign will
she ever actually get it
and senate democratic candidate tom
mcdermott
smoked pot in a political ad to
celebrate yesterday being 4 20.
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
don't miss it sign up at joinpakman.com